policy is figuring out what problems you
can solve and how and what problems you
cannot solve and then what you do about
them and that's that's what the people
at the thing thanks ought to be doing
and it ought to be very practical and it
ought to be in the national interest
that doesn't mean there's just one
national interest and they've all got to
agree but it's got to be reasonably done
it can't be politicized and ideologies
it's got to make sense and it's that
quality of common sense that I think
we've lost in a lot of the think-tank
work and it's got to be based on
ultimately a realistic notion of power
because that's still how you get things
done in the world